appear weak when you are strong
and strong when you are weak
if you know the enemy
and know yourself
you need not fear the results
of a hundred battles
let your plans be dark and impenetrable
as night
and when you move
fall like a thunderbolt
in the midst of chaos
there is also opportunity
victorious warriors win first
and then go to war
while defeated warriors go to war first
and then seek to win
to know your enemy
you must become your enemy
there is no instance of a nation
benefiting from prolonged warfare
treat your men
as you would your own beloved sons
and they will follow you into the
deepest valley
even the finest sword plunged into salt
water
will eventually rust
move swift as the wind
and closely formed as the wood
attack like the fire and be still as the
mountain
opportunities multiply as they are
seized
there are not more than five musical
notes
yet the combinations of these five give
rise to more melodies
than can ever be heard
when the enemy is relaxed
make them toil
when full
starve them
when settled
make them move
who wishes to fight must first count the
cost
if you wait by the river long enough
the bodies of your enemies will float by
know yourself
and you will win all battles
[Music]
to win 100 victories in 100 battles
is not the acme of skill
to subdue the enemy without fighting is
the acme of skill
[Music]
build your opponent a golden bridge to
retreat across
be extremely subtle
even to the point of formlessness
be extremely mysterious even to the
point of soundlessness
thereby you can be the director
of the opponent's fate
the whole secret lies in confusing the
enemy
so that he cannot fathom our real intent
what the ancients called a clever
fighter
is one who not only wins
but excels in winning with ease
rouse him
and learn the principle of his activity
or inactivity
force him to reveal himself
so as to find out his vulnerable spots
you have to believe in yourself
if the mind is willing
the flesh could go on and on without
many things
thus the expert in battle moved the
enemy
and is not moved by him
attack is the secret of defense
defense is the planning of an attack
great results can be achieved with small
forces
ponder and deliberate before you make a
move
if quick i survive
if not quick i am lost
this is death
ultimate excellence lies not in winning
every battle
but in defeating the enemy without ever
fighting
if you ignore both
your enemy and yourself
you are certain to be in peril
move not unless you see an advantage
use not your troops unless there is
something to be gained
fight not
unless the position is critical
wheels of justice grind slow
but grind fine
it is easy to love your friend
but sometimes the hardest lesson to
learn
is to love your enemy
if his forces are united separate them
you can't trust a man
who has nothing to lose
plan for what is difficult while it is
easy
do what is great
while it is small
if he sends reinforcements everywhere
he will be weak everywhere
be where your enemy is not
an enemy is a friend who knows too much
about you
disorder came from order
fear came from courage
weakness came from strength
if your friend is friends with your
enemy
it means that you should not hang out
with this friend
[Music]
beware of sugar that is mixed with
poison
beware of the fly that sat on a dead
snake
who does not know the evils of war
cannot appreciate its benefits
therefore
just as water retains no constant shape
so in warfare there are no constant
conditions
regard your soldiers as your children
they will follow you into the deepest
valleys
look on them as your own beloved sons
a leader leads by example not by force
he will win who knows how to handle both
superior
and inferior forces
in making tactical dispositions
the highest pitch you can attain is to
conceal them
[Music]
strategy without tactics
is the slowest route to victory
tactics without strategy
is noise before defeat
the captured soldiers should be kindly
treated and kept
one need not destroy one's enemy
one need only destroy his willingness to
engage
every animal with blood in its veins and
horns on its head
will fight when it is attacked
never trust a friend
who is silent about your flaws
[Music]